[Musique]
et aujourd'hui j'accueille la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires
jacqueline gourault bonjour jacqueline
gourault bonjour nous sommes ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour un entretien et
on va commencer d'abord par parler de
l'actualité de l'hôpital avec le plan
dévoilé hier par le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand notamment pour augmenter
les salaires augmenter les
investissements dans l'équipement et
pour organiser une grande concertation
avec les acteurs hospitaliers
est ce que ça veut dire que le
gouvernement n'avait pas mis assez de
moyens pour l'hôpital depuis trois ans
cela veut dire tout simplement que la
crise sanitaire a démontré tout d'abord
l'hôpital et est très agile très
adaptable que les hommes et les femmes
qui font vivre l'hôpital c'est à dire
des soignants et bien en entrée une
adaptation absolument remarquable devant
cette crise majeure et qu'il faut bien
sûr continuer en tirant les leçons au
fond de cette crise pour adapter encore
mieux l'hôpital et montrer au fond dans
le temps long que cette souplesse est
quelque chose de très important
et ceci nécessite sûrement des annonces
nouvelle le
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
a annoncé à nouveau il a appelé ça le
ségur le ségur de la santé et se sera
réuni le 25 mois mais c'est à dire ce
mois ci une rapidité exceptionnelle pour
répondre aux besoins de l'hôpital et des
soignants oui le grand seigneur de la
santé en référence à l'avenue de ségur
où siège le ministère de la santé alors
l'hôpital et soupe mais il faut
également des moyens pour l'hôpital et
d'ailleurs le président de la république
emmanuel macron a dit la semaine
dernière qu'il avait fait une erreur de
stratégie vis-à-vis de l'hôpital c'est
important de faire son mea culpa il a
dit qu'il y avait peut-être pas lui
comment dire suffisent à une ampleur
suffisante à la réforme de l'hôpital et
c'est bien de le dire ma santé 2020
avait des choses très intéressantes
moi personnellement je trouvais que tous
ceux qui étaient destinés à la
modification des études de santé pour
attirer plus d'étudiants dans les études
de santé me semblait très important donc
je ne crois que tout n'est pas à défaire
il faut construire encore plus et
surtout aussi l'engagement pris par le
président de la république c'est eux le
métier entre guillemets de médecins de
soignants au sens large soit plus
attractif et donc mieux rémunérés est ce
qu'au fond cette crise sanitaire n'a pas
montré le manque de moyens de l'hôpital
at il quand même flagrant
cette crise a montré comme je les dis
une très grande adaptabilité de
l'hôpital mais elle a montré aussi qu'il
faut avoir
comment dire un plan plus mieux mieux
prévu plus prévu si je fais dire pour
des cas de crise salutaire comme celle
ci et là on sent bien qu'il faut donner
plus de souplesse aussi à la gestion
d'hôpital alors on va entrer dans notre
deuxième semaine de déconfinement quel
premier bilan faites vous de cette
première semaine de déconfinement
je crois que les français d'une manière
générale ont vécu cette première semaine
de manière raisonnable de manière
progressive et je le vois par exemple
vous avez annoncé aujourd'hui
l'ouverture des lycées des collèges
pardon en zone verte qui va concerner
plus de cent cinquante mille élèves on a
vu que pour les écoles primaires les
choses se sont bien passées
progressivement avec des différences
selon les zones géographiques mais avec
des accueils entre 20 et 30 % des élèves
ce qui est une réussite et ça s'est bien
passé
il ya quand même un point négatif sur
les enfants plutôt défavorisé où
beaucoup finalement ne sont pas vraiment
rentré dans les écoles vous avez raison
ceux qui sont revenus le plus facilement
à l'école sont les enfants de ce qu'on
appelle les csp + et que en fait les
enfants plus défavorisés ou la plus
grande difficulté qui sont souvent
d'ailleurs les mêmes sont moins vite
revenus à l'école et le ministre de
l'éducation nationale l'a dit lui même
il faut un véritable plan de retour à
l'école de ses enfants alors l'actualité
du jour c'est bien sûr la rentrée dans
les collèges c'est également l'entrée en
fonction de plus de 30000 conseils
municipaux élus dès le premier tour
le 15 mars dernier cette installation
des conseils municipaux elle est vitale
pour relancer politiquement les
territoires elle est très important
d'abord en termes démocratique puisque
depuis le 15 mars
des équipes nouvelles âmes été élu donc
il est important qu'elles puissent se
met en place
et deuxièmement bien sûr on sait le il y
a les communes mais aussi derrière les
intercommunalités qui joue un rôle
absolument fondamental dans la vie des
territoires faire vivre les territoires
et compris l'économie
on sait que l'investissement public et
et est assuré par don à 70 % par les
collectivités territoriales j'y rajoute
bien sûr les départements et les régions
mais ce qui est important là c'est que
les exécutifs vont pouvoir à telus
aujourd'hui vous avez raison aujourd'hui
18 mai c'est la fin au fond du
prolongement des équipes sortantes et
c'est l'installation officielle de ceux
qui ont été élus le 15 mars est donc
dans les trente mille communes qui
avaient élu leur conseil en entier
jacqueline gourault une question sur les
résultats de ce premier tour je rappelle
qu'il ya eu 55 % d'abstention il y
actuellement plus de 3000 recours devant
les tribunaux administratifs et
d'ailleurs des députés la république en
marche demande un avis du conseil
constitutionnel sur la validité de ce
premier tour des élections municipales
est ce que vous comprenez le doute de
ses élus sur les résultats de ce premier
tour les élections ont lieu les
résultats ont été programmés maintenant
que je pense qu'il faut passer à
l'installation des exécutifs qui auront
lieu comme vous le savez entre le 23 mai
et le 28 mai c'est à dire à partir de ce
week end à partir de samedi jusqu'à
jeudi prochain et je peux vous dire que
sur le terrain c'était une attente très
importante des élus et je pense que
maintenant il faut passer à autre chose
et imaginez peut-être ce que vous allez
annoncer dans la journée puisque le
premier ministre va voir dans la journée
avoir le résultat du conseil
scientifique et voir dans quelles
conditions peuvent se passer
le peut se passer par dont le deuxième
tour de ces élections
justement on aura donc cet avis du
conseil scientifique sur la possibilité
d'un second tour au mois de juin ont des
confine actuellement les commerces les
écoles on a du mal à imaginer que des
élections ne pourrait pas avoir lieu au
mois de juin l'écouté on va voir ce que
le conseil scientifique 10 et
le premier ministre vient sur rendra à
ce moment là comme c'est prévu son avis
devant le parlement et le premier
ministre a souhaité d'ailleurs qu'il y
ait une discussion à ce sujet au
parlement
et d'ailleurs on va en parler de ce vote
du parlement sur la date du second tour
mais avant cela et bien les maires des
grandes villes met un peu la pression
sur le gouvernement pour organiser
absolument ce second tour
au mois de juin est ce que vous
comprenez et bien leur leur empressement
car ils ne veulent pas je cite de
confinement démocratique nous avait
aussi les élections n'avaient pas lieu
en juin ce qui est bien sûr dans le
domaine du possible
le conseil d'état a été très précis a
déclaré que dans ce cas il faudrait
refaire deux tours puisque au fond entre
le premier et le second tour il a jugé
qu' au-delà du mois de juin
évidemment il y aurait une distance et
un temps trop long
donc un certain nombre de maires dont
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de france
urbaine par exemple n'ont pas très envie
si je puis dire de refaire un premier
tour et c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est une raison majeure bien sûr pour
vous pour eux par dont ils ont envie que
les élections se passent avant la fin du
mois de juin
mais on verra évidemment quels seront
les annonces aujourd'hui et en même
temps est ce qu'il ne serait pas
nécessaire et bien de rejouer les deux
tours car on va quand même être sur une
élection avec un premier tour avant la
crise du cornât virus et un second tour
qui succède à une crise sans précédent
ça n'a rien à voir on peut tout imaginer
mais enfin on est dans un temps que le
conseil d'état considère comme
raisonnable moi je crois prix il faut
plutôt aller au bout de cette élection
mettre en place les exécutifs des élus
du 15 mars vers le second tour et je
dirais passer à autre chose et faire en
sorte que nous notre pays reparte avec
ces institutions complètement à ce
palais
pour vous il faut privilégier la relance
du pays à la validité démocratique d'une
élection
les deux si je puis dire l'âme à l'unité
démocratique de l'élection du premier
tour elle n'est pas remise en cause par
les 38 communes qui ont été élus alors
dg bien entendu ce que vous m'avez dit
des parlementaires peuvent toujours
s'interroger mais je n'ai pas entendu et
vous me direz si vous avez entendu le
contraire des élus revendiquer
l'annulation du premier tour alors on va
parler du vote du parlement sur cette
date du second tour le gouvernement est
favorable à ce que le parlement est bien
se positionne sur cette date votes
valides
la date du second tour au mois de juin
est ce que le projet rappelle que le
président du sénat gérard larcher lui
est défavorable un vote du parlement car
il estime que les parlementaires n'ont
pas autant d'informations sanitaires sur
le gouvernement pour ce que le
gouvernement pour se prononcer qu'est ce
que vous pensez du refus de gérard
larcher de voter sur cette date on le
sénat aura toutes les informations
puisque naturellement comme le
gouvernement l'a fait depuis le début de
cette crise dans une totale transparence
et le parlement sera informé de la
situation sanitaire sur laquelle
d'ailleurs la décision va être prise en
salle c'est un des éléments de prise de
décisions majeures
donc évidemment qu'il y ait un débat au
parlement ne fera qu'aller dans le sens
de la transparence et de la connaissance
de la situation sanitaire
donc je trouve que c'est au rouge c'est
une manière d'informer le parlement qui
est positive et très importante
c'est une manière aussi pour le
gouvernement de partager la
responsabilité avec le parlement
d'organiser ces élections en juin
c'est une manière au fond oui si vous
voulez de partager la comment dire la
décision de faire un deuxième tour
d'élections municipales mais d'un côté
vous avez toutes les associations d'élus
qui s'exprime
qui
donnent leur avis qui sont
majoritairement effectivement pour que
le premier le deuxième tour pardon et
lieu en juin
ah oui vous m'entendez jacques bigot
oui mais j'avais quelqu'un d'autre sur
les ondes c'est pour ça j'ai été un peu
je reprends jeudi toutes les forces
politiques sont donnés même leur avis
participe elle même au débat donc je
trouve que c'est normal que le parlement
il pas aussi une question sur le
parlement un neuvième groupe politique à
l'assemblée nationale va se créer avec
des frondeurs des ex-députés la
république en marche également des
écologistes ça veut dire que c'est la
fin de la majorité absolue du groupe la
république en marché à l'assemblée
nationale ça veut dire aussi que votre
parti le modem va prendre plus de poids
finalement dans le paysage politique
français
vous savez le modem a toujours joué le
rôle qui est le sien c'est-à-dire un
rôle d'un parti politique qui je vous le
rappelle avait pris position pour
emmanuel macron avant le premier tour
des élections présidentielles qui a fait
un choix en début d'année d'année 2010
est bien évidemment et qui a toujours
joué son rôle dans la majorité
deux propositions et et de comment dire
de participation constructive à toutes
les décisions de la majorité alors l'un
des prochains textes à arriver au
parlement et bien ce sera le troisième
budget d'urgence pendant cette crise du
corps est venue du coronavirus et ce
budget d'urgence il va contenir un plan
de soutien en faveur des finances des
collectivités locales qui ont perdu
beaucoup de recettes financières durant
cette crise sanitaire quelles sont les
pistes de ce plan de soutien aux
finances locales alors des réunions de
travail sont organisées régulièrement
par le mini gérald darmanin et olivier
du soft et nous mêmes ici au ministère
de la cohésion des territoires
c'est à dire avec sébastien lecornu et
moi même
et ça c'est une discussion permanente et
récurrente que nous avons avec les
différentes ce tract d'associations
d'élus
par ailleurs comme vous savez le premier
ministre a confié à un député et le
président de la délégation collectivités
territoriales de l'assemblée nationale
jean rené cazeneuve la mission d'évaluer
ce que là comment dire ce que la crise a
provoqué au niveau des collectivités
territoriales aussi bien dans la partie
recettes de la partie dépense alors
quelques pistes me dites vous d'une
manière générale il apparaît que il est
très important de travailler sur les
recettes des collectivités territoriales
et on a déjà vu ou cibler des choses qui
qui sont évidentes
la crise pour les communes touristiques
qui ont beaucoup moins de rentrées ou
encore la baisse de l'octroi de mer pour
les communes d'outre-mer ou encore les
dm théo c'est à dire les fameux frais de
notaire qu'encaisse les collectivités
territoriales pour les départements et
certaines communes on sait très bien
on a déjà ciblé mais il faut évaluer et
faire en sorte effectivement de trouver
les moyens de soutenir les collectivités
qui en ont le plus besoin
je voudrais peut-être préciser c'est que
nous sommes très attentifs au fait de la
crise n'a pas touché de la même manière
toutes les collectivités territoriales
et donc qu'il faudra faire attention
nous semble-t-il d'avoir des comment
dire des politiques de soutien qu'ils
soient particulièrement ciblés sur ces
collectivités territoriales donc ça va
être plutôt des aides ciblées en faveur
des collectivités et pas des mesures
générales
en tout cas dans un premier temps pour
cette année 2020 là où il y a urgence il
faudra des mesures ciblées ensuite pour
la loi de finances
prochaine pour 2021 on verra s'il faut
aussi adapter des politiques
structurelles pour les collectivités
territoriales
et justement on va parler de l'avenir
des compétences de ces collectivités
territoriales car avant cette crise du
coronavirus jacqueline gourault vous
prépariez et bien une nouvelle loi de
décentralisation la loi 3d qu'on appelle
la loi 3d pour décentralisation
différenciation et déconcentration est
ce que cette crise sanitaire finalement
elle va changer votre loi non je crois
je le confesse oui et non non dans la
mesure où les 3d que vous venez de
rappeler la signification sont apparus
avec cette crise sanitaire comme une
vraie nécessité et voyez par exemple le
mot de déconcentration montre combien
l'état
la présence de l'état sur les
territoires ce qu'on appelle l'état
territorial est quelque chose de
fondamental
on a vu le jeu rôle très important
qu'ont joué les prêts créé sur les
territoires et vous avez vu comment le
premier ministre et le président de la
république on dans cette crise
associés en permanence les préfets et
les maires au plus près du terrain donc
on sent bien n'est ce pas qu'il y à tous
cette crise conforte au fond l'idée de
déconcentration également je pense de
décentralisation on voit bien aussi que
par exemple dans le domaine sanitaire
il faut donner aux terrains plus de
liberté d'agir d'agilité et la
différenciation tombe sous le sens
puisque c'est un mot qui utilisaient par
tout le monde maintenant car on voit
bien que le territoire ne serait ce que
dans cette crise sanitaire ont été
touchés différemment et en justement sur
le domaine sanitaire est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement que vous allez donner
plus de compétences en matière sanitaire
en matière de santé au département alors
nous n'en sommes pas là
nous sommes en première semaine de
déconfinement comme vous venez de le
rappeler nous allons petit à petit
reprendre le travail de concertation sur
les territoires avec les départements
aussi naturellement
et évidemment ce sera à nous tous
ensemble de tirer les conséquences de
cette crise sanitaire
mais vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
les départements demande est bien plus
de pouvoirs en matière de santé les
régions en matière d'économie vous
qu'est ce que vous en pensez avant la
concertation
alors d'abord je pense que d'une manière
générale dans la loi notre qui a été
voté par le gouvernement précédent il y
avait des choses qui n'étaient pas
forcément de bonnes idées mais il ya eu
une ligne qui a été qu'on a
comment dire clarifier les compétences
des collectivités territoriales
personnellement je pense que cette
clarification a été salutaire et qu'il
ne faut pas revenir sur tout cela et
touche à lutter par contre mettre plus
de souplesse permettre dans les
relations horizontales entre les
collectivités territoriales plus de
souplesse c'est quelque chose qui me
semble très intéressant
une question de calendrier jacqueline
gourault quand est ce que cette loi 3d
pourrait arriver au parlement
agenda n'ai aucune idée vous savez cette
crise a profondément touché notre pays y
compris sur le plan du déroulement de la
vie politique au niveau national et
institutionnels il est évident qu'il
faudra que dans les semaines qui
viennent les priorités soient définies
par le gouvernement
ce sera un texte quand même d'arriver en
2020 ou ses reporters 2021 je ne peux
pas vous donner de réponses précises car
nous n'avons pas encore préparé le
calendrier de la praye confinement c'est
à dire des étapes du déconfinement ce
que je sais c'est que il faut faire
repartir le pays
il faut faire repartir la vie
démocratique democratic la vie
économique
la vie sociale c'est absolument
fondamental et naturellement c'est ce à
quoi nous allons
travailler dans les jours qui viennent
jacqueline gourault rapidement une
dernière question sur le sénat une
assemblée que vous connaissez bien
puisque vous avez été sénatrice pendant
15 ans comment vous avez accueilli le
lancement l'annnonce du lancement en
juin de la commission d' enquête du
sénat sur la gestion du gouvernement
dans cette crise sanitaire
écoutez chacun à son calendrier
peut-être que si on m'avait on n'avait
pas à me demander mon avis puisque je
n'ai plus sénatrice mais dans une
période de difficultés majeures comme
celle que nous connaissons
je crois plus à la concorde nationale
car des signes qui peuvent affaiblir
l'unité de la nation
merci beaucoup jacqueline gourault
d'avoir été notre invité alors juste
pour savoir quand est-ce qu'on reverra
un ministre un membre du gouvernement
sur un plateau de télévision
écoutez quand le gouvernement prendrait
dès fillon voilà d'accord mais on sait
pas décider
très bien merci beaucoup jacqueline
gourault d'avoir était notre premier
invité politique du déconfinement et
demain à votre place ce sera eric
coquerel député la france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis